okay so tell me about the recording
process man are you recording strictly
in the studio or same as with the iPad
are you kind of recording everywhere so
I like the studio I like the space of
being in the studio I got my own stew at
the crib so get comfortable there but I
record all over and
I love it man I'll just you know a lot
some of some of my tracks just come from
like freestyling for 30 minutes and then
picking out the spots like oh that's the
flow right there take that and then
build off of that so A few songs kept
about three I literally talk about the
process in the hood I rap for 14 minutes
on this beat then I kept three but at
first I was sending everybody that 14
Minute Freestyle because I was really
excited about it but it was in November
2020 which was a perfect time to send
people 14 minute freestyles because
nobody was going anywhere so they
listened to it yeah so some of those is
from you know starting from long
freestyles and then revisiting them
and being like okay I should structure
this like an actual song
I've just recently gotten more into a
strong song structure
into intros and and and you know hooks
and and whatnot